qui va frapper ce qui me frappe dans ce
débat monsieur mitterrand je vous le dis
très simplement c'est que vous êtes un
homme du passé
c'est ce qui m'a frappé j'aurais
souhaité que nous parlions de l'avenir
j'aurai souhaité trois fois je ne peux
pas parler de l'avenir avec vous on a
l'impression que l'avenir ça ne vous
intéresse pas et dans cette élection
présidentielle si je représente quelque
chose si je crois à quelque chose c'est
à l'avenir de la france c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
vous êtes un homme du passé toutes
votées vocation à propose que je propose
c'est elle passait c'était 1969 c'était
1962 c'était 1945
on a l'impression vous voulez pas
regarder l'avenir de la france et si
vous ne voulez pas regarder jus
mitterrand vous ne conduirait pas bien
cet avenir alors à provo tête à venir je
dirais ceci pour ma part je souhaite que
la france ne prenne pas pour elle et
pour les français
un risque qui peut être mortelle le fait
de bouleverser profondément notre vie
politique
notre vie économique notre vie sociale
c'est pour un pays est encore un pays
fragile parce que la france est un pays
fragile
c'est un risque qu'on ne peut pas
prendre et donc ce que je propose à la
france c'est en effet le changement mais
c'est le changement qui exclut le risque
il ne faut pas croire que le choix que
les françaises et les français vont
faire c'est un choix pour quelques
semaines pour quelques mois
on cherche à leur présenter cette idée
mais c'est un choix pour ces temps une
fois que ce choix sera fait il sera
irrévocable
si les structures économiques politiques
et sociales de la france on sont
transformés ou sont détruites elles
seront détruites ou transformées
irréversiblement et non pas seulement
sur des points de détail
mais dans leur structure mail de leur
nature lorsque je souhaite pour ma part
au contraire c'est le changement c'est à
dire le développement le progrès de ce
qui a été entrepris alors on me dit que
ce changement c'est seulement le
changement d heure non monsieur
mitterrand c'est le changement d'une
génération et ses changements d'hommes
qui ont dans l'esprit et dans le coeur
la préoccupation de l'avenir dans l'est